هيه هيهم بالسياره هيهم في وضح النهار
وحده من قوه المستعربين العسكريه
الاسرائيليه دخلت الى اكثر الشوارع حيويه
وسط مدينه
[موسيقى]
الهدف اغتيال القائدين في كتيبه جنين نضال
خازن من سرايا القدس الجناح العسكري لحركه
الجهاد الاسلامي ويوسف الشريم القيادي في
كتائب القسام الجناح العسكري لحركه حماس
كان معا على دراجه هوائيه جنود وحده
المستعربين باغتوهما واطلقوا وابل من
الرصاص عليهما
اكتشف الاهالي امرهم
وحاولوا محاصره سياره المستعربين الذين
اطلقوا النار على كل من هاجمهم الى ان
تدخلت وحدات من جيش الاحتلال اخراج
السياره عقب ذلك اشتباكات مسلحه بين
مقاومين وقوات الاحتلال انتهت باستشهاد
فتى ورجل فلسطينيين واصابه اكثر من 23
اخرين
الاهالي يتقدمهم عشرات المقاومين المسلحين
من اذرع المقاومه كافه صاروا في مدينه
جنين يحملون نعش الشهداء الاربعه ويرددون
شعارات تطالب بالانتقام ومواصله المقاومه
وعلى المستوى الابدي والسياسي الفلسطيني
تزداد نبره الغضب حده ما كان لهذا الذي
يجري من جرائم ان يستمر لولا المعايير
المزدوجه التي تمارسها الاسره الدوليه
وشعور الجنان قتله بالافلات من العقاب
اكثر من 88 شهيدا سقطوا برصاص الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي خلال شهرين ونصف تصعيد ياتي في
ظل مساعي القياده الفلسطينيه الى مطالبه
المجتمع الدولي وفي مقدمته الولايات
المتحده بالضغط على حكومه اليمين
الاسرائيليه خاصه عشيه قمتي شرم الشيخ
الناطق الرسمي باسم الرئاسه الفلسطينيه
اكد ان المجزره الجديده تهدف الى تفجير
الاوضاع وقال ان هذه الاعمال التي وصفها
بالعدوانيه تؤكد ان اسرائيل غير معنيه
بالتهدئه خلافا لكل الجهود الدوليه السعيه
لمنع التصعيد في شهر رمضان
الجهود الدوليه وخاصه الامريكيه تتواصل
فالمبعوث الامريكي الخاص هادي عمرو يواصل
التحضير لقمه شرم الشيخ بهدف وقف التصعيد
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه القمه تعقد برعايه
ام ريكيه مصريه اردنيه رغم عدم التزام
حكومه الاحتلال بالتفاهمات التي ابرمت في
قمه العقبه الشهر الماضي الجزيره رام الله